for the final talk of the workshop you
have Thomas case in hand presenting
possible online algorithms and in your
skin mother yeah thank you thank you all
for so being here I'd like to talk about
a very simple technique that you can use
actually to design online algorithms
when you have kind of a probabilistic
input most importantly if your input
comes in random order like a no less
talk and I'm actually going to start
with a problem that that allah is
mentioning namely the multiple choice
itary problem so this is the extension
of the secretary problem where you're
allowed to select up to K elements so
once again what does this mean we have n
items that arrive online over time and
each of them has a weight these weights
are adversarial but the order in which
we see them is uniformly drawn from all
possible permutations and upon arrival
of an item we immediately have to decide
whether we take it or whether will you
reject it the constraint is to accept up
to k items and the objective is to
maximize the sum of the weights of the
accepted items so the problem this
problem has actually been solved at
least the way I want to think about this
by Bobby more than 10 years ago showing
that there is a 1-0 of 1 over square
root K competitive algorithm whereas
competitive Fraser it's just the same as
in the talk before so when you always
compare the expected value that your
algorithm achieves with the optimum
value that an offline algorithm could
achieve so in this case this would be
just the value of the K best items and
yeah I claim Bobby solved this because
he also showed that this you can only
improve this in terms of constants
before this in terms of constants you
you have in this otero ok so to present
the technique that I'd like to
illustrate to you I'm now going to give
you an algorithm for this problem which
is actually optimal which is close to
the one that Bobby proposed but it's not
exactly the same so the algorithm is the
following just suppose you know you're
in around l and item J arrives and by
that I mean so you remember the talk ola
gave he was always saying that well
first you you drop some elements that
you just don't do anything you always do
this with every item that you see you
always do this um now you're into this
else round you know that overall you'll
be seeing n items so because of the
random order how many of the opt items
have you seen so far in expectation well
in expectation you've seen an L over n
fraction of the optimal solution so um
I'll over n times K of the items that
you're supposed to pick so let's just
try to imitate this let SL now be the
set of the L over n times K best items
that we've seen so far ok and now we
just ask well is the the item that is
the item that just has arrived is this
one among these best L over n times K
best that we've seen so far in that case
and well have we accepted too many and
both have we accepted less than K items
so far in that case it's applet
otherwise rejected so that's that's the
entire algorithm and I claim that this
algorithm is actually optimal so let's
just try to prove that and to prove that
let's now consider a round l which is
not right at the beginning or right at
the end of the sequence so you you know
k is supposed to be a large number so
you're not in the first epsilon on the
last epsilon fraction of your input then
I claim the following things are true so
let's talk about the value that this set
SL actually produces so I was claiming
we're in the L throne we've seen an
elver infraction of the the opt
items now well we are now taking the
this L over n this is an expectation now
we're taking the best l over n times K
items that we've seen so far okay and
what might not happen it might not
happen that these are actually we've
seen more than L over n times K or we
might have seen fewer than elbow and
times K in expectation it's just right
so just assume that we've seen fewer
than l / NK items of the the OP tiles
well then obviously this set SL contains
all of the opt items that we've seen so
far might not be that we've actually
seen more than that and then we're
losing some of them so we can actually
account for this by just taking that by
now banning the expectation of the value
that we've seen so far of our set L this
is at least L over n times opt times
well this correction factor which just
actually means when we see more than the
expected number of items well we
actually kept by this and we only take
the best l / NK items that we've seen so
far so that's actually easy to compute
that's just capping a binomial
distribution at its expectation you
would have to subtract the the standard
deviation that's all you have to do for
that okay now what does the the item
that we're trying to select contribute
so what do I mean by that well just now
suppose let's now consider this value
here which is the value of the item
times the indicator do we want to take
this item so I now set CL 2 1 if it is
contained in this head SL otherwise I
set it to 0 so that's the value that I
want to get in this particular out round
and then I claim that this is actually
in 1 over L fraction at the value of
this set SL why is this true well this
set SL that doesn't depend on the order
in
first L items arrive and therefore we
can just consider the the health item
and so the item that comes in the elf
around being drawn uniformly from the
set and so therefore an expectation this
just contributes a the the item that we
want to select kinding non selecting and
not not trying to select a 0 that's just
the one over i'll fraction of this value
of the set s SL so combining these
things we see oh well actually the value
that we're getting an expectation from
our from items that we want to select
this is opt over n times something
that's like 1 minus absolute just think
of this as 1 minus absolute of course
this these are the values of the items
that we want to select now might still
happen that we're actually not selecting
this item because well we've selected
too many already but I claim this is
also not a problem so what's the
probability that we are actually running
into a conflict here well that's not
seen the expected the expected number of
items that we're taking this is a bit
mostly expected number of items that we
wanted to take and by actually the same
kind of argument that we had on the
previous slide the probability that I'm
trying to take an item in a particular
round that's K over N and so you can
just do the same thing here and now you
just apply a concentration bound namely
while we do this pattern of maybe you
could also do this differently and then
you get that well if your L so if you're
in not too late in the sequence you have
a pretty decent probability that you
didn't run off out of your budget so
this is actually all you have to do now
you got these two inequalities and you
just plug things together you have now
that the value that you're getting from
round L this is just like opt over n
times 1 minus epsilon times 1 minus
epsilon now the the exact numbers matter
to
get the the right asymptotic guarantee
but this is the general idea so one
thing that you might no be afraid of is
that things might be correlated in a way
yes they are surely correlated in a way
actually in this case this is no big
problem because all this algorithm is
just comparison based so you don't have
to worry about this this will be
different in what I'll explain next but
still things will work out so in the
following target and I would like to
present two examples where we actually
extend this technique to more complex
problems and the first one I'd like to
talk about is online packing our Peas
this drawn back with class vodka and
dressed tennis and better tracking from
like two years ago so and the setting
here that's actually setting that we've
seen already in a couple of thoughts so
what do you have here this is now a
general linear objective function linear
constraints and all of these
coefficients are non-negative and now
you variables x j in your LP these
arrive one after the other and whenever
you see a variable you have to set its
value immediately irrevocably so you
might see that in this case it might
actually be be reasonable to choose
fractional values and this is actually
the thing that we would comparing two so
we be comparing our solution to the best
fractional solution but our solution
will be integral one thing that you
could model for example is the multiple
choice secretary problem they would just
have a single constraint here this
matrix a is totally boring because this
would be all ones and on the right-hand
side you would just have the the number
of items that you can accept okay now
once again what's the model here we have
an adversary that fixes in advance these
constraint matrix a the capacity of
vector B the objective function back to
see and now the variables arrive one
after the other in random order and in
advance we know the number of variables
and the capacitor
vector and B the coefficients we get to
know whenever the respective variable
arrives and exactly at that point in
time we have to set its value so do let
me first give you some more notation
that I'll that be important let's just
assume we have M constraints in total
and of course we might have um might be
a sparse LP so there might be fewer than
M then M nonzero entries or let me state
this differently just take any column
and count the number of nonzero entries
that you have in that column so in a
sparse LP that might this will be a lot
smaller than the number of constraints
bird and generally it's always upper
bounded by the number of constraints so
this is what we call d and another
important parameter is the capacity
ratio so what's that take one row of
your LP and I compare the right-hand
side to the greatest entry that you
actually see in that in that particular
row take the minimum over all of these
just as a sanity check what boot this
before or modeling the the multiple
choice secretary problem while the right
hand side this was the number of
elements that we can select in total so
this is our K and each of the
coefficients was one so this would be
exactly our K and voice is an important
parameter well we might know that if
this B is large then the integrality gap
gets small it even approaches one and a
similar thing is now true for this
online LP problem in the random order
namely that you can get 1 minus epsilon
competitive algorithms if this B is
large in F and priority our work there
has been there have been a couple of
results in this flavor so you always
read these as like they have a 1 minus
epsilon competitive algorithm if B for
foods isn't that bound
okay so you don't have actually to look
at the at the precise numbers here you
see these are always like polynomial in
em and one over epsilon our result is
now the first to actually get a much
better guarantee than that namely we get
a 1 minus epsilon competitive algorithm
if B fulfills this bound so you see this
is lock the over epsilon squared I was
saying d is always smaller than M Saudi
was the comp sparsity m was the number
of constraints so therefore this is an
exponential improvement and not only
this this actually matches the lower
bound by this paper but agrawal long
edgy so there's one other thing these
previous algorithms and also I should
mention there are a couple of follow-up
and papers in more in this direction
these are all like primal dual
algorithms which does have some some
advantages to this edge which does have
some advantages however our algorithm is
doesn't use any LP theory whatsoever and
I think you might even know what our
algorithm looks like if you followed the
first part of my talk let me go through
it roundel now variable XJ arrives so
you now we've now seen in an elver n
fraction of our LP so let's now solve
this LP if you remember we before we
have to set SL of the best L over n
times K items this now corresponds to
the optimal solution to the known LP and
we now scale the capacities x factor l
over n we've seen an elver infraction of
your of our LP so we also scale the
capacities and one important thing that
I have to mention that we ignore
everything that we've done so far so
just solve the LP ignoring every single
value every single LP variable that
you've set to any value just solve the
LP and now well this gives you a
fractional allocation to the
variable that you are currently dealing
with so just use this as a probability
as an usual randomized rounding and set
it to one with exactly this probability
and now I asked well what this now be a
feasible allocation so would i get a
feasible LP solution after i do this and
that case i do this otherwise I don't um
okay and I claim that this algorithm
actually gives you 1 minus 0 squared
lock the over B fraction of the optimal
LP value in expectation and you see this
actually recovers also the the optimal
guarantee for the multiple choice
secretary problem where you're this log
B would just be one and as a matter of
fact I claim both like the week of work
you would be able to do this analysis
yourself you just have to derive the
exact same inequalities now it's a
little more tricky because uh well why
are things in independent so before I
could claim oh well you know this is
only comparison based this is not true
anymore because you cannot solve them an
LP just based on comparisons but at this
point will trust me or talk to me about
this and that actually things are
independent enough so that we can
actually do this stuff and then we can
just add up the inequalities and we just
get the exact right guarantee that we're
hoping for okay
so this is the D algorithm and this was
our guarantee once again actually in
that if your capacity so that this only
makes sense if this B is at least log D
because otherwise you just said say well
I get at least a zero fraction of my
optimum but actually this algorithm also
gives you a good guarantee or a decent
guarantee if your B is not large so even
if your B is only like two you still get
a get it decent guarantee and I think
our algorithm is the first one and that
gives you a guarantee at all for the
setting that UB is not large and
furthermore you can actually add like a
sampling face like in other algorithms
that work in random order and you can
reduce this to than 21 and then you're
actually pretty close to what's best
known even for the offline case for for
just solving a general integer packing
program or by by randomized rounding
okay so this is one way of applying this
technique let me now come to you one
other way of applying this technique
which is the temp secretary apartment is
don't work with andreas tennis and
disappeared in this year and this
problem is actually really nice it was
introduced by by amazon quarters last
year so it's pretty similar to the
multiple choice secretary problem so
again you have items arriving over time
and each of them has a weight but now
each of them has like a length which you
could think of as a duration of how long
it stays in the system and now you
constraint will be that you're supposed
to only accept up to k items that are
active at the same time now how does
this know I get again have adversarial
weights and now I have a slightly
different arrival model namely that
these but I have arrival times that are
drawn I ID from a distribution which
might be the
the uniform distribution which is
actually would be equivalent to two
random order except for the fact that
now I now have these lengths so I
actually need this notion of time in my
model and the rest is just the same sub
upon arrival of an item I have to
immediately to decide to take it to a
rejected and my attractive is again to
maximize the sum of the weights of the
accepted items yeah right we are about
evidence arm my algorithm will be
parametrized in an upper bound on the
length but there's no need ok let me
come to this later on let me first give
you very quick examples that I think
you've understood it by net but just to
have a visual impression of what this
might look like so you might miss this
is your time axis and now this item of
value five camps and in bull for example
if you know if K is one you're allowed
to accept only one of your items
simultaneously sure this would then
block all of this time so yet if we take
this then we cannot take this guy so
then we have this value of five but
we're losing this value of 20 so we have
to reject it and if you see while would
I accept this guy of value one probably
not because he blocks all this time here
so I can't accept anybody arriving
during their time so let's reject him
and then instead we see this this guy
and turn out to be actually good idea so
let me come to our algorithm and i'm
just going to explain to you our album
four identical lengths it and later on
come to to some extensions so arm let's
make a very important observation so if
not all of your items are in the system
for length gamma how many can you accept
well obviously you cannot accept more
than K over gamma why is that because
there's just not
more space in there so what can we do
well we can actually just try to select
exactly the best k of a gamma guys and
this is actually just the same algorithm
I'd had throughout the top trying to
select the best k of a gamma guys sure
that sounds like a good idea the problem
is I might not even be able to really
accept these because I now have these
much more complicated constraints and
which were like you shouldn't accept
more than one item or more than K items
simultaneously so therefore you would
now have to check whether this is
actually a a feasible schedule but if it
turns out you can actually do the math
and show that this algorithm is a half
time minus 0 of root gamma competitive
and actually you can't get better than a
half here this was in this previous
paper by Fiat at all and also if K grows
large you get an even better guarantee
of course one thing I should also
mention is that for gamma being one you
can accept only a single item overall so
therefore you can't hope that this is
that you get the half independent of
your gamma because for if you're able to
select only a single guy then the best
that you can hope for is one ovary and I
think the nice thing about this
algorithm that it's now immediately
clear how you could extend this to two
other settings so for example if you now
had instead of this cardinality
constraint allowing you to only select
Kate items what if you had like
complicated packing constraints well
it's actually pretty clear what you want
to do so the only thing is you have to
find this relaxation and this is even
possible if your lengths are different
so the that maybe even the easier case
to see if you if your lengths are
different then this is actually this
and this relaxation that we're using
this would actually be more like a
knapsack constraint but even then things
work out although I have to admit that
the analysis gets kind of complicated
because then you have what I didn't tell
you about throughout this talk was the
dependencies and these might break your
neck here well at least we don't know
how to analyze all of your algorithms
that you can come up with here all right
let me wrap up here I hope I've given
you a very simple template template for
online algorithms and what's the idea
just pretend you could start from
scratch now what would you do well
please leave some space for whatever
comes later on but that's the general
idea and that turns out to give you the
optimal guarantees for multiple choice
secretary problem and for online packing
LPS it gives you simple and better
algorithm for the temp secretary problem
I'm actually not sure if we hit the
exact exact optimal guarantees because
there's no impossibility results so far
or except for the ones that I told you
about and this approach interestingly
also works if you have like a submodular
objective function and what could not be
open problems going from here what about
for example cost minimization problems I
think this is generally very interesting
direction to go to in all of these
probabilistic models what can you do
with stochastic models actually we have
kind of a proof of concept that alter
this at Birth make approach can give you
something in a cost minimization
contacts but I think there's much more
to do and one other thing that I
consider really important is what about
non uniformly drawn permutations for
your random input or generally weakening
the assumptions on your stochastic input
so we have a paper with that about we
had in last year but this was only for
the very basic secretary problem and all
of these comments are generalizations
we're still not
to to deal with and this is also related
to my third bullet point I think it
would be really good to actually have
algorithms that work in multiple models
at the same time so there are a couple
of results this this way now for example
Bob told us but one yesterday and I
think this is a really important
direction to go to all right so that's
all I wanted to talk about i think it's
now my honor to thank the organizers for
a very great workshop and i thank you
all for still being here analysis get
much arm so the question about an iid
input i don't think it gets much easier
so one thing that you could claim is
that if you just instead of having this
random order iid seems a bit simpler
because you'd have fewer dependencies
however well you still actually have
some dependency because what you're
selecting in this round kind of depends
on what you saw in previous rounds and
therefore also depends on what you did
in these previous rounds so therefore
it's i don't think it will get a lot
easier so maybe at some point you can
say well this is now iíd some things
might become easier but generally i
don't think it gets a lot easier so what
thank secretary do you use the fact that
the period is contiguous or it could be
fragmented oh come on sorry well the
tapes record you probably the
interpreters contigo so it could be
fragmented part of toothless drama arm
is actually the result that I was
talking about right now this only works
for the uniform distribution this way so
you can also do this for the uniform
distribution on 0 1 which is well 0 1
with this without loss of generality
we've tried to extend this to like other
distrib
and there is actually an obvious way how
to extend this however we didn't get
better than the baseline approach where
you would just divide your time into
fragments and just solve the basic
secretary problem on it on these
fragments so unfold the honest answer to
your question is very good or at least
we don't know
so one of this question is also so right
now you're aware that the temp secretary
hired for a 30th period oh yes you know
if it's just a volume arguments because
you know what it said the visibility
argument isn't just a volume argument I
would have to double check but this is
not just a volume argument so definitely
the theory elation that's a volume
argument but not all of the proof is a
volume argument